so as daniel said i'm corey i work on
open source swift libraries at apple
foundational
server-side swift libraries and i'm not
going to talk about that today i'm going
to talk about
a different passion of mine and an
interest of mine which is cryptography
and the reason i want to talk about it
is that
fundamentally
cryptography is everywhere
this is a a pretty recent development in
in software engineering it used to be
the case that you could at least hope
that you wouldn't have to think about
cryptography too much in your day-to-day
development you were reasonably
confident there were very smart people
somewhere far away from you who thought
hard about cryptography but you yourself
didn't have to to think about it to plug
it into things or to worry about that in
any kind of particular way
unfortunately this is not true today
nowadays you find it everywhere
and one of the most common places you
find cryptography is in client-to-server
communication the kinds of things that
we do all the time
you can find this in forms of transport
layer security the underlying uh
protocol that encrypts the web usually
not something you yourself have to
write directly
but you will find it in things like api
tokens jwts are incredibly common you'll
find request signing schemes anyone
who's used aws will see that you need to
frequently sign data bodies
you will see things like secure
credential storage answering the
question how do i store user passwords
how do i store api tokens in a way that
keeps them safe and secure
there are of course more esoteric use
cases things we touch less frequently
but are nonetheless incredibly important
there are things like distributed
identity management trying to spread
across multiple machines notions of
either user or service identity
there are things like uh schemes for
delegating authority if anyone has used
oauth you're familiar with at least one
scheme for delegating authority but
there are a number of others uh some of
them have excellent names things like
macaroons often food related uh says
something quite a lot about
cryptographers i think
and there are is obviously everyone's
favorite secure messaging software
something that has become an
increasingly major part of our lives and
something that software developers touch
more and more
nowadays your average software developer
is more likely than ever
to have to deploy some form of
cryptography in their applications even
if it's something as small as hashing
some data this is regardless of their
development environment it's regardless
of how you conceptualize yourself as a
software developer it's beyond things
like back end or front end whichever end
you think you operate on you are likely
to have to touch cryptography
for swift we've had a number of
libraries to uh work with cryptography
but the one that has mattered the most
for client developers recently uh is
cryptokit and i'd like to talk about
cryptokit uh just a little bit cryptokit
is a brand new apple system library it
was introduced at wwdc 2019 which i hope
many of you were at
uh this was in the session cryptography
on your apps i've given you a nice
citation there if you'd like to go watch
this session
its goal is to be a swift first
cryptography library that provides
expressive apis for performing
cryptographic operations securely and
efficiently
the particular area of focus here is to
provide high level apis which are
resistant to misuse
and this notion of misuse is something
i'm going to want to come back to later
on in the session
cryptokit takes advantage of many of the
powerful abstractions of swift the kind
of things that we've talked about in
previous dot swift conferences things
like value types things like generics
and things like reference counting
this gives your code powerful tools that
perform well and most importantly are
easy to use and hard to misuse
it's got a lot of features a lot of
tools for letting you perform important
cryptographic tasks a number of hash
functions people love a good hash
functions got all of the sha2 family of
hashes including some older and less
secure ones
it provides hmacs for validating
integrity of data it provides a number
of ciphers called aead ciphers which are
the gold standard way to encrypt data
they protect you against malicious data
modification and in the absence of
anything else are the kinds of things
you should use in your apps
and it provides a full suite of
implementations for asymmetric
cryptography everyone's favorite thing
to try to deploy using elliptic curves
this includes full support for both key
exchange and signing and verifying using
the major curve standardized by nist and
the extremely popular curve 25519
this is a suite of features that cover
the most important use cases that people
have today and provides a clean focus on
primitives and apis that are easy to use
so why is cryptokit important why did i
want to talk about misuse so much
the biggest risk when you are writing
cryptographic code is that it is very
very difficult to tell the difference
between code that is correctly executing
the operation you liked and the code
that is doing so in a way that is unsafe
or failing to achieve its goal i don't
know about you but when someone hands me
a string of random bytes i can't tell if
they're encrypted or not this is the
nature of encryption when it's working
it looks random but looks random is not
a very clear metric and it's not a
secure one
this happens because most cryptographic
primitives have an extremely wide range
of ways in which they can be configured
and they have a lot of configuration
options
this leads to apis that are extremely
hard to use they bombard you with
questions that only an expert can be
expected to have sensible answers to and
many experts do not have sensible
answers to
often all you want to do is encrypt some
data in a way that you can safely store
it and retrieve it later but you will
get asked tricky questions like what
block cipher mode do you like is ecb
cool what about cbc hmm difficult
initialization vectors what is one how
do i get one what do i have to do with
it
padding what is padding does it matter
nothing in this api thus far has
reminded you that you might need to
authenticate your data the most
important thing for you to do here and
the thing that the api doesn't ask you a
question about
this has led to a lot of papers being
published pointing out the weaknesses in
many cryptographic libraries with code
that touches cryptography often being
called the most dangerous code in the
world users are expected to be experts
in order to use these libraries
correctly and if anyone in here has
worked with some of the pre-existing
low-level apis like openssl
you may be familiar with what i mean
these difficult-to-use apis have led to
a number of vulnerabilities in all kinds
of products in the software industry and
this is an unacceptable state of affairs
for our industry to be in
as a result there's an important school
of modern cryptographic api design
focusing on misuse resistant apis the
goal is
to provide the user with a limited
number of choices all of which are
secure
in a way that is makes it very hard to
achieve sub-optimal outcomes from the
api if you ask for encryption you should
get the best possible version without
being forced to make too many choices
about what that might mean that could
diminish the value of your result
cryptokit is an important piece of this
design work
it aims to provide these misuse
resistant apis
but
cryptokit is an api that is only
available on apple platforms and here's
the thing none of the problems i just
outlined are specific to developers on
apple platforms
unfriendly difficult to use
cryptographic apis are rife on other
platforms as well
it's important that our entire industry
be working together
to build better safer cryptographic apis
to ensure that as much of our computing
is as secure as possible
the reason is
many applications that run on apple
platforms have components that run on
other platforms they have back-end
servers or web app versions for other
platforms
often these other components need to do
similar work to the client application
they're a critical part of the
cryptography pipeline and they must also
handle the data correctly
to that end i'm thrilled today to be
able to announce our newest tool for
helping developers navigate this subtle
and important space
swift crypto
thank you
swift crypto is a fully open source
re-implementation of the cryptokit apis
that is supported absolutely everywhere
that swift is it is available right now
licensed permissively under the apache 2
license available for swift 5.1 and
later using swift package manager in a
package that is semantically versioned
the package contains two major chunks of
code the first are the definitions of
the public api of cryptokit these files
are the original versions from cryptokit
itself and have been made open source as
part of swift crypto
they are accompanied by a brand new
implementation of those apis that uses
google's boring ssl library
this means there are now two peer
implementations of the cryptokit apis
the first available on apple's platforms
uses apple's proprietary core crypto
library and the second available
everywhere else uses boring ssl
we have implemented every single api in
cryptokit that does not rely on
specialized hardware
that is any api that we can expect to
run on a reasonably wide range of
hardware has been fully implemented
this is the overwhelming majority of the
api surface of cryptokit
so if crypto is available in the swift
package manager without any platform
restriction
when you use it as a dependency on an
apple platform
it delegates to the system copy of
cryptokit passing all api calls directly
through
on any other platform it will use the
open source implementation instead
so what does this look like
perhaps you want to encrypt some data
with swift crypto this is an extremely
straightforward operation you'll notice
the encryption itself is only one single
line of code
you'll also notice that there are no
awkward questions here like what not
should you use or what your data format
look like these all these decisions are
made for you
this in kind of encryption is safe to
use in almost all contexts it's the kind
of encryption you might want to use if
you're storing data somewhere your app
will decrypt later or to send to another
person that you have a pre-negotiated
secret with
perhaps instead you want to validate
that some data you've stored somewhere
uh was stored safely or that has been
correctly and actually sent by the
remote service you expect
and that it hasn't been tampered with
for that you use something like a
message authentication code in this case
something like hmac cryptokit gives you
yet another one-liner for doing that and
switch crypto gives you the exact same
one
hmac is a vitally useful primitive that
is used in a surprising number of places
you might not expect especially in
client to serve a communication where we
get some great advantages out of having
swift crypto for example you can find it
jwts macaroons both technologies for
authenticating in networked systems
and as a final code example consider
generating a shared secret using
elliptic curve diffie-hellman that is
the most technical sentence i'm going to
utter today
those of you not familiar this is a
primitive that allows two individuals to
share data publicly
but come up with a secret that only the
two of them can possibly know
this is nothing short of mathematical
magic i highly recommend reading about
it if it's the kind of thing that sounds
interesting to you the math is
surprisingly straightforward
this is how you would generate such a
shared secret in cryptokit like the one
i talked about earlier you could pass
such a share you could use such a shared
secret to generate a key for encryption
purposes and you can see that cryptokit
does this in just a few short lines of
code it's shorter than it looks if you
don't try to make the text large enough
to be read from the back
so
what parts of crypto kit does swift
crypto support
i said earlier what doesn't rely on
specialized hardware but to be more
specific essentially everything the only
rule
is that if you see the words secure
enclave that api has not been
implemented in swift crypto it will
continue to function only on apple
platforms that expose a secure enclave
the implementations in swift crypto are
entirely compatible with the ones in
cryptokit
we share the same test suites
we can test the two implementations
against each other
everything we do is also done by
cryptokit
one of the other important areas of
focus for us in this work other than
making sure these two libraries were
perfectly compatible together was to
make sure that we could evolve swift
crypto going forward
with open source projects it's extremely
important that the community is able to
guide the evolution of the project and
to propose new apis to that project as
well as to fix bugs and improve the
infrastructure around the project they
use so i'd like to spend the remaining
time talking a little bit about what our
plans are for evolving this project
the core api of swift crypto everything
that is immediately available
will remain in sync with crypto kits api
as it stands on the latest releases on
apple platforms on which swift crypto is
uh which cryptokit is supported that
means whenever new api is added to
cryptokit we will be adding it to swift
crypto as well except where that api
relies on specialized hardware
of course that covers the case where we
at apple would like to add new apis
but as i said earlier it's important the
community must be able to propose ideas
for new apis as well
we are defining a process for adding new
core api this is an api that will
eventually become a fully fledged api in
both cryptokit and swift crypto
this will allow the wider community to
propose new apis that will eventually
make their way onto apple platforms
this has an extraordinarily high bar to
entry
both in terms of the quality of the api
being proposed and the importance of the
feature that is being added
it is very important that these features
will be widely used and have vital
client-side uses
features like this will follow os
release cycles we will not be releasing
new api in the swift crypto main
namespace until such an api ships in
cryptokit as well
and i want to stress something important
here both swift crypto and cryptokit do
not intend to support every
cryptographic primitive in the world
shipping new api and cryptokit implies a
substantial support burden as it does on
swift crypto and the threshold for
wanting to take on that burden is very
very high
this means most attempts to add new api
servers to switch crypto will be
rejected
but
not all and the most important ones will
be added
i also want to stress something about
redundancy
in many cases there is redundancy in
cryptographic primitives there are many
ways to encrypt data
there are many stream and block ciphers
most of which have strange names and you
have never heard of
we do not intend to support every
primitive that has ever been conceived
or even everything that you can find in
the wild
instead we want to target the common
useful core of the api surface the goal
is to focus on a safe shared set of
implementations
this is the goal
so
we're coming towards the end
how do you get involved with swift
crypto
there are lots of ways the source code
is open source
available at our github repository
either now or shortly depending on my
colleagues in the united states
this repository is also where you can
file issues
when you file issues these issues should
be focused to swift crypto if you need
to provide feedback about cryptokit
itself please continue to use the
feedback process that you use today
if you want to suggest new api you can
also do that on github we have a
template for api proposals please read
it and please use it if you want to file
new api proposals
if you want to provide an implementation
of your new api proposal please do so as
with all open source projects and as we
heard with erica as with swift
all issues and suggestions for
improvement are better if they have
accompanying code they are much more
likely to be accepted
otherwise
please use swift crypto
please discuss it on the swift forums
reach out with feedback from using it
tell us if you find limitations or if
things are awkward or unhelpful we would
love to know what you're using it for
what limitations you find and any of
your other thoughts
we are very very excited to see what
you're going to do with this brand new
library if there's anything you'd like
to chat about please find me after the
session on twitter or the swift forums
and on behalf of absolutely everybody
involved with swift crypto we are so
pleased to be able to share our work
with you today thank you very much